حسنًا ، أنت خبير يعرف كل شيء ،
يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا بشأن الأعمال التجارية ، يمكنك تقديم المشورة لنا
بشأن الحياة ، فأنت
متحدث تحفيزي لرائد الأعمال ، كما هو جاد ،
يسعدني جدًا أنك
معنا هنا اليوم ، وأشكرك أيضًا على ذلك.
الكثير من التسويف ، حسنًا ،
إنها لعنة حياتنا في وقت ما ، هل
يمكنك أن تخبرنا كيف يمكننا التعامل مع هذه العادة؟
يماطل الناس
بسبب واحد من شيئين ، الخوف والخوف
هو الشيء الذي أرغب في
محاربته في العالم ، فهم
قلقون حقًا من أنهم إذا فعلوا هذا
الشيء ولم يسير على ما يرام
والدتهم خالتهم أفضل ما لديهم  صديق
أختهم
سيحكم عليهم زميلهم في العمل وهم
يعيشون حياتهم بشكل أساسي بناءً على
رأي شخص آخر أو رقم اثنين
وهذا مثير جدًا للاهتمام ، فهم
لا يحبونه حقًا
وقد يكون ذلك جيدًا في الواقع  قد يكون من الجيد
أنك لا تحب المدرسة ولا
تحب العمل اليدوي في المنزل
ولكن لا يزال يتعين إنجاز الأشياء
وفهم كيفية المثابرة من خلال
الأشياء التي لا تحبها ، إنها مجرد
رحلة حياة يربطها الناس
بالتسويف  الكسل نعم
ولكنك قدمت لنا شرحًا آخر كاملًا
له ، نعم ، أعني أنني من أقل
الناس كسلاً الذين أعرفهم ، لكنني أؤجل
في الكثير من الأشياء ، لذا
أعتقد أني أفهم سبب قيام الناس
بذلك.  لقد تحدثنا
عن التسويف لفترة طويلة ، أنا
فقط لا أرى الأمر بهذه الطريقة ، حسنًا عندما
تشعر بالكسل ، هل هناك
روتين صباحي معين تفعله حتى
تتمكن من التخلص من هذا الكسل
والبدء حقًا  أعتقد أن ما
يحفزني هو الامتنان عندما أستيقظ
ولا أشعر بذلك ، فأنا دائمًا ما
أذهب إلى مكان الامتنان الذي
تعرفه ربما لا أشعر به ولكن بعض
الناس لا يملكون حتى  خيار
الاستيقاظ هذا الصباح ، فأنت تعلم أن بعض
الأشخاص لديهم أشياء يصعب التعامل
معها أكثر مما يجب عليّ الآن ، ولذا فإن
أحدهما أميل إلى الامتنان والآخر هو
حب الذات وقلة الحكم ، فلا بأس
حتى على أعلى المستويات  لديك
صباح يوم أربعاء حيث لا
تشعر أنه ليس عليك أن تضرب
نفسك ، أعتقد أن الشيء الذي
يحدث لكثير من الناس هو أنهم يدخلون
في دوامة ويستيقظون يوم
الأربعاء لا يشعرون بذلك  ثم
فجأة ذهبوا إلى هذا
المكان المجنون ، مثل رائحة كريهة ، أنا سيئ ،
بدأوا في ضرب أنفسهم ، وبدأوا في
نشر أحكام التدمير الذاتي
بطريقة صحيحة ، ثم يبدو الأمر وكأنه
دوامة هبوطية وهذا صعب للغاية
للخروج من ذلك وبالنسبة لي ، فإن الطريقة التي أذهب بها هي
واحدة من نقيضين متطرفين من الامتنان العميق كما
قلت ، وهو أمر يشبه نعم ولكن كأنني
محظوظ جدًا ، دعنا نذهب أو سيكون اليوم
أحد تلك الأيام من أصل 365
يومًا  في هذا العام حيث سأكون
محبطًا قليلاً ، لا بأس بذلك
كما لم يكن لدي ، وبالنسبة لي
من المفترض أن أكون دائمًا على مستوى العالم
من أجل عائلتي لموظفيي ، لكن لا
بأس في الحصول على بعض  في تلك الأيام وفي
كثير من الأوقات بمجرد أن تكون لطيفًا مع
نفسك وتقول إنه على ما يرام بحلول منتصف النهار ، يمكنك
نوعًا ما تحويل
الأموال بسرعة ، نعم ،
هل تعتقد أنها موجودة ويمكن أن تستمر ،
هل هي موجودة ، أعني أن هناك العديد من
السيناريوهات في  آخر 30 عامًا حيث
تمكن الأشخاص من جني الكثير من المال
في فترة زمنية قصيرة جدًا ،
أشعر بقلق شديد تجاه الأموال السريعة لأنني
أعتقد أنها تخلق إطارًا
ضعيفًا بشكل لا يصدق
وأنت تعرف جيدًا أنه ليس منطقيًا بمعنى
أن الكثير  من الأشخاص الذين يكسبون
أموالًا سريعة كانوا يبحثون عن Fast Money
وأنت تعلم أننا جميعًا نشاهدنا مرة أخرى
رأينا أشخاصًا يكسبون أموالًا
يخسرون أموالًا ، ويخسرون أموالًا ،
ويخسرون أموالًا ، وأعتقد أن هذا يرجع إلى أنهم
يقامرون أكثر مما
يفعلون  البناء
وهكذا بالنسبة لي ، فإن المال السريع دائمًا ما يكون
مصدر قلق ، وغالبًا ما يتحدث عن عقلية Gold Rush التي
رأيناها في أرض nft ،
نراها في سوق الأوراق المالية ،
ونراها في أشياء جديدة ناشئة
مثل الحشيش ، هناك الكثير  من
الأشياء حول العالم عندما أنظر إلى أنها
خلقتها ، فإن العديد منهم يمتلكون
أعمالًا مستدامة جدًا طويلة الأجل فيها ، إنها
مجرد استثناءات RP
هناك أوقات استثنائية تخلق
لحظات مختلفة وقد رأينا هذا
مرارًا وتكرارًا إنه مجرد شيء  كن
متعبًا منك أعلم أنه شيء يجب أن أشعر
بالضجر منه لقد كنت دائمًا قلقًا للغاية
بشأن مفهوم كسب الناس للمال بسرعة
على Tick Tock ، أليس كذلك
نسبة مئوية صغيرة نعم كما هو الحال بالتأكيد هناك
مئات الآلاف من الأشخاص وهذا
كثير  نعم ، لكن ليس كثيرًا مقارنة
بـ 8 ملايين وثمانية مليارات ، عفواً ، أعني ،
لكن لا تنس
أنه لم يكن سريعًا جدًا كما تعلم أنني كنت أصنع
مقاطع فيديو حول رموز التجزئة والفرصة
لمدة خمس سنوات الآن ، إنها الأخيرة  24
شهرًا حيث حقق نطاقًا حرجًا وكان
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين صنعوه
يصنعون أيضًا محتوى على Vine على Snapchat على
Instagram والآن لديهم لحظاتهم
داخل الشركات بعض الأشخاص لديهم
عقلية حيث يدخلون ويريدون
تخطي عدة مستويات في
المسار الوظيفي ويريدون فقط أن يصبحوا رئيسًا تنفيذيًا
على الفور ،
أعتقد أن ما تشير إليه هو
الاستحقاق
ولذا أعتقد أن الاستحقاق
سيء ، نعم ، أعتقد أن هناك نقصًا في
الصبر يرغب الناس في الترقية
بشكل أسرع اليوم من  لقد فعلوا ذلك
قبل 20 عامًا 100 لكنني لا أحكم على الجنرال Z
لأن الكثير من الناس يشبهون أوه ،
فالعالم أسرع ، نعم كل شيء
أسرع ، لذا لا أحكم عليه ولكني
أفهم أنه
نقطة الضعف الكبيرة هي ريادة الأعمال
للجميع ، يحب الكثير من الناس التحدث
عنها أنا رائد أعمال
أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك لكنهم يتحدثون
في الحياة الواقعية عندما يتحدثون مع
أنفسهم فقط ، يدركون أنهم لا يريدون
هذا الضغط  إنهم لا يريدون أخلاقيات العمل تلك ،
فهم لا يريدون هذا الألم ، كم عدد
الساعات التي تعمل بها يوميًا ،
ربما في الملعب من
10 إلى 15 ساعة.
بالنسبة لي ، الأمر مختلف بعض الشيء ، كما
تعلم ، أعتقد
أنني ضمن مجموعة صغيرة جدًا من الأشخاص الذين
يحبون ما يفعلونه كثيرًا ، إنه يشبه
هوايتهم ، من الصعب جدًا بناء
شركة إذا كنت قائدًا في
ثمانية-  ساعة من العمل ، من الصعب جدًا أن
تعرف ما هو الاكتئاب الشديد.
شائع جدًا لا أعتقد أن المال يغير
الإطار العاطفي الداخلي للناس ،
أعتقد أنه في الواقع يسرع الأمر ، أعتقد
أنه إذا كنت في مكان جيد جدًا ، فإن
المال يسرع من هذه الحقيقة ، أعتقد أنه إذا
كنت في مكان سيء للغاية ، فإن المال
يسرع من أنك  قادرون على تحمل
الهروب وآليات المواجهة الأخرى ،
لذا أعتقد أن هذا أمر شائع جدًا ولكن أعتقد أن هناك
جميع الأطر التي أعتقد أن هناك
أشخاصًا لديهم الكثير من المال ، وهم في سلام كبير
جدًا
ومكتئبين ، حسنًا ، غاري ما يفعله الوقت
تستيقظ
عادة في حوالي الساعة 6:30 إلى 7:30
صباحًا على ما يرام ، لذلك تكون الساعة 6:30 في
منزلك في نيويورك ،
ما هو أول شيء تفعله لقد قمت
بفحص هاتفي ، لأن هذا المؤسف
يعود إلى ضغوط كونك
رجل أعمال لأن  شركتي
عالمية ولدي مكاتب في لندن
وسنغافورة وفي جميع أنحاء العالم ، يجب أن
أتحقق من هاتفي للتأكد من
عدم وجود أي شيء مشتعل ، حسنًا ، تحدث إلينا مثل روتينك اليومي.
أنا سعيد وبعد ذلك أنظر في رسائل
البريد الإلكتروني والنصوص الخاصة بي لأرى مجرد الحصول
على الأرض ،
ثم عادةً ما أعمل على الفور
ثم ما إذا كنت آخذ أطفالي إلى المدرسة أم
لا أحد هذين الأمرين ثم
أبدأ  العمل ، نعم اثنين ،
وهكذا بالنسبة لي ، فأنا أعمل بشكل أساسي بحلول الساعة الثامنة والنصف من العمر تمامًا ،
ولا أتناول
الغداء حقًا ، لذا فأنا أعمل على طول الطريق من خلال
سبعة وثمانية وتسعة وعشرة اعتمادًا على
اليوم الذي هو يومي ومتى تستريح
في عطلات نهاية الأسبوع ، هل لديك أي هوايات
مثل هل نعم أي شكل من أشكال التنفيس
خلال اليوم
عملي هو التنفيس الخاص بي ، أنت تعلم أن هذا
يعود إلى النقطة كما لو أنني لست
قلقًا جدًا أو متوترًا بسبب
عملي عندما غادرت بيلاروسيا  هل يمكنك
التحدث إلينا عن طفولتك
أكثر من ذلك بقليل ، لقد ولدت في الاتحاد السوفيتي ، لقد
غادرت عندما كنت في الثالثة من عمري ، لذا لا
أتذكرها حقًا ، لقد
أتيت إلى الولايات المتحدة عندما كان عمري ثلاثة أعوام
ونصف لأنني  لقد استغرق الأمر بعض
الوقت للوصول إلى الولايات المتحدة وأنت
تعلم أننا نشأنا
بتواضع شديد جدًا لقد عشت مع
أجدادي العظماء وجدتي والدي عمي
وكان الأمر
متواضعًا جدًا في كوينز نيويورك ،
أم أننا عشنا هناك من أجل
بعد ذلك بعامين انتقلنا إلى نيوجيرسي
آه في إديسون نيوجيرسي ، حيث
بدأت حياتي بعدة طرق وهذا هو
المكان الذي تبيع فيه أكشاك عصير الليمون
بطاقات البيسبول حيث
كانت روح المبادرة الخاصة بي رائعة حقًا
ما هو أفضل مجال للاستثمار فيه  الشرق الأوسط
لكل من يشاهد
الشيء الأول الذي يجب أن يستثمر فيه هو الأشياء التي تفهمها وتعرفها ،
لذا فإن الكثير من الناس أعني
أن هذا ربما يكون السؤال الأكبر الذي
أحصل عليه من Gary ، أين أضع أموالي
في شيء تفهمه جيدًا  كما
لو كنت من عشاق الموضة
وتحبها حقًا ، فاستمر في قضاء
بضع ساعات إضافية في البحث عن الموارد
المالية والوقائع التجارية
للعلامات التجارية الثلاثة أو الأربعة المفضلة لديك ،
وربما يكون أفضل شيء تفعله هو
شراء أسهم lvmh لأنك  أنت تفهم ذلك ،
والشيء الآخر الذي يجب البحث عنه هو إذا
كنت تفعل في مرحلة مبكرة ، فانسى أمر
الاستثمار في الشخص كمستثمر
ملاك ، هل أنت قلق بشأن
مستقبل الاستثمار في الشركات الناشئة في
ضوء انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي؟
لا أشعر بالقلق في حد ذاته لأنني
أعتقد في الواقع
أن ما سنراه يخرج من هذا
هو القليل من الأموال التي يتم إلقاؤها في أشياء
ليست أعمالًا قابلة للتطبيق
بطريقة غريبة ، فأنا أقل قلقًا ولست مهتمًا أكثر
لأنني أعتقد  الكثير من المال
والتمويل يفعل ذلك هو أنه يخفي الكثير من
نقاط الضعف في شركة ناشئة وأن
الكثير من الشركات الناشئة لم يتم بناؤها
فعليًا على بناء الأعمال التجارية ولكن من خلال
التحول إلى شركات هندسة مالية ، فإن
كل ما يفعلونه هو زيادة رأس المال ولذا
أعتقد مع  رأس مال أقل أو أكثر
تكلفة رأس المال ، ستجبر
الشركات على أن تكون أعمالًا تجارية حقيقية
تعرفها بنفسك كرجل
أعمال متسلسل ، نعم لا يعرف الكثير من الناس
المصطلحات ، هل يمكنك من فضلك
توضيح أنك تعرف أنني لا أعرف
ما هو تعريف المسؤول الذي تعرفه  هو
نعم ، تعريفي هو أن لدي الكثير من
الأعمال التجارية التي أريد أن أفتح المزيد منها ،
أفكر فقط في الأعمال التجارية
وأريد إنشاءها والاستثمار
فيها ، لذا فأنت تعرف بالنسبة لي أن
الجزء التسلسلي لرائد الأعمال هو أنه
يتحدث فقط عن حجمه  يتحدث عنها إلى
الأبد ، إنها تتحدث عن أنك تعرف أنك
تفعل هذا حتى آخر نفس لدي على
الأرض ، وهكذا أرى الأمر حسنًا ،
غاري سؤالي الأخير لك هو أن الدردشة
ستحل محلني ،
لا أعتقد ذلك  كاتب
أعتقد أن ما سيحدث هو أنه
سيعززك حقًا حسنًا ، لذا فإن
ما يفتقده الناس بالذكاء الاصطناعي
هو أنه يأخذ السلعة
ويجعلها أكثر كفاءة ، لذلك نحن نسير
جنبًا إلى جنب ، أعتقد أنك تسير جنبًا إلى جنب
لأن الشيء الحاسم  التفكير في أنك
بحاجة إلى إدخال
في أحد برامج الذكاء الاصطناعي هو في الواقع
الجزء الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام ،
وبالتالي سيوفر لك الوقت
بدلاً من الاضطرار إلى كتابة
كل شيء ستقوم بتحرير
مخرجات أفكارك الخاصة
، لذا أعتقد أن هذا سيسمح لك  لك في
الواقع أن تكتب مقالات أفضل
لأنك ستحصل على مزيد من الوقت
للتفكير
ووقت أقل في القيام بالسلعة مما جعلك
مطمئنًا جدًا في الواقع ،
أنا سعيد جدًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك.